then you ask well how do you contend
with things wisely and I would say well
don't pollute your thoughts with deceit
you compromise your own wisdom how are
you going to make intelligent not
Intelligent Decisions wise decisions
that's why you shouldn't lies like
you're warping the mechanism that
orients you in the world if you really
want to do that this is a brutal world
man and I've seen this in my clinical
practice
people whose houses are built on
foundations of sand and the wind starts
to blow and the floods start to rise and
they are in such trouble
such trouble if you're lucky
and something terrible comes your way
and you're reasonably honest and your
relationships are in good order maybe
you won't end up in hell
you you need to be afraid of that it's
like don't lie we're all subject not
least to the Judgment of our own
conscience try to escape from that
thank you
hey what's going on everybody it's
December 9th 2022 I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report if you have not
already subscribed to our
rumblechildrumble.com Ruben report if
you want to play along during the show
in live chat and communicate directly
with me and much more Ruben
report.locals.com uh and I wanted to do
a cold open of that nature what you just
saw and heard right there as opposed to
sort of the more silly ones that we
usually start the show with because
these Twitter files dropped last night
it's Twitter files part due and uh well
it's big it's really really big and I
think as we find out more and more about
how big the lies that have been pushed
on us are how pervasive they were at
almost every level
of our supposed trusted institutions uh
well we're going to have to do some work
to to reclaim the truth we're gonna have
to do some work to understand how so
many people got so many things wrong
over the last couple years so I'm going
to catch you guys up on this massive
Twitter drop which for those of you that
have been playing along with me for the
course of the last let's say six years
or so a lot of this is not going to
surprise you because it's stuff as
you'll see uh throughout the show today
it's stuff that I was talking about on
the show literally five six years ago
about Shadow Banning and what's going on
and how it's distorting reality and how
I often say that social media was
supposed to be a mirror for society so
you could put something out there and
you could get an honest reflection back
to you but it became a fun house mirror
and really the more that we've been on
social media the harder it's been to be
social and to get truth and all of these
things so that really is going to be the
uh the theme of the show today and I
thought another really nice way to start
this would be with a famous quote that
you've heard me mention a couple times
on the show a famous quote by Russian
novelist Alexander solchenitzen who was
born in
1918. he was one of the most famous
Soviet dissidents he was an outspoken
critic of Communism he raised Global
awareness for the political repression
that was happening in the Soviet Union
and then of course he wrote the gulag
archipelago which Jordan Peterson
references often the quote right here we
know they are lying they know they are
lying they know that we know they are
lying we know that they know that we
know they are lying and they still
continue to lie
yeah that's right and that's kind of
where we're at right now so what do we
do the genius
of what Elon Musk has done here it is
starting to become obvious to me he did
not necessarily buy Twitter for the
money
the guy's got an awful lot of money
he's working on rockets and he's working
on connecting our brains to computers
and all sorts of other stuff right
he did not buy this company for money he
bought this company because I think it's
becoming clearer and clearer that he saw
the same problems that we all see the
problems that we talk about on the show
every day the problems that you guys see
all the time that social media
big Tech
big government
corporate press the collusion between
these two things to distort our reality
and give us a fake narrative rather than
a true assessment of what's going on
here has been so massive and so
pernicious because it's part of
everything and it's really hard to see
that you can only look back of these
last couple years and go boy you know if
you really went completely bananas
it's not all your fault what do I always
say it's like if you stayed roughly sane
over the last couple years that's pretty
good you're good to go in my book
roughly saying not totally sane and some
people could say Dave you're only
roughly saying that's just fine but
there's a reason that so many people
went crazy and that reason is because so
much so much of our information was
filtered through a social media lens
that was designed to lie to us that's
what the Twitter files are all about uh
and you are we are going to lay out a
case today you are going to see it from
the top down from Jack Dorsey at Twitter
the former CEO who lied literally to me
on Twitter and we've got the receipts
about whether they shadow man or not uh
to a whole bunch of other people that
have been part of this thing you're
going to see it so
should we get to it I think we should
get to it I think we got the idea we've
got the new blueprint it's from Elon
Musk and here we go so
I want to start with a tweet that I sent
out about two years ago uh this was a
response to Jack Dorsey so Jack Dorsey
at the time this is in October of 2020.
Jack Dorsey was the CEO of Twitter now
when you're the CEO of the Twitter the
buck stops with you you're in charge so
he wrote our communication around our
actions on the New York Post article was
not great and blocking URL sharing via
Tweeter dm with zero context as to why
we're blocking unacceptable so obviously
he's talking about the hunter Biden
laptop and Twitter's Behavior related to
all of that now remember this is over
two years ago so I responded with a
rather simple question I did not expect
to get a response lo and behold I did I
said do you Shadow ban based on
political beliefs simple yes or no will
do and Jack with two letters that I
think he will come to regret wrote no
okay this is super interesting so he's
saying that they don't Shadow bad now
when I saw the response and as I always
tell you with these things I don't mean
to make this about me I happen to be
close to a lot of these things which is
weird but I want to give you a sort of
personal Insider view of this and then
we'll get to the sort of bigger issues
and and the totality of what they've
done here
um my feeling when he responded to me
and said no we do just by saying no so
no we don't shadow man it didn't mean
much to me because it was like oh you
how do we Define Shadow ban right it's
an it's a new term it's not in the
Webster's Dictionary so he's probably
playing some linguistic game here maybe
they don't call it Shadow Banning they
call it subtle hiding or whatever
definition of Shadow Banning he has is
slightly different than the one I have
but the point is the way that most
people understood Shadow Banning the
idea of Shadow Banning over the last
couple years was the idea that you would
tweet something out or you would post a
message somewhere or post a video and
the algorithm or somehow manually and we
did not know until we now have some
information we'll get to that in a
moment would depress the views on that
so it's Shadow band as opposed to
outright band because an outright band
you know what happens right if you're
banned you're suspended you you get an
email you can't get into your account
you know you're gone Shadow Banning was
far more nefarious because the idea was
you think that you're still getting to
your people you think your voice is
still being heard but they're doing
something on the back end either through
AI through the algorithm or through
actual employees that were manipulating
feeds we know it's actually both now so
I want to just go to two tweets of mine
that you guys have heard before uh
relative which got me suspended over the
years because then I think we will get
right into the to the long Twitter
thread so as you remember uh this one
was back in July of 2021 they want a
federal vaccine mandate for vaccines
which are clearly not working as
promised just weeks ago people are
getting and transmitting covid despite
the vax plus now they're prepping us for
booster shots the same Society would
take pause we do not live in a sane
Society okay you guys have heard me talk
about that one Fox News covered it we'll
do this real quick for you conservative
pundit I guess I'm a conservative pundit
Dave Rubin revealed that he had been
suspended from Twitter for merely
tweeting news about famed Canadian
psychology and psychology professor and
philosopher Jordan Peterson's own
suspension from Twitter we're gonna I'll
read you that tweet in just a moment
Reuben's offending tweet from June 29th
read the insanity continues at Twitter
Jordan B Peterson has been suspended for
this tweet about Ellen Page he told me
he will never delete the tweet on June
22nd Peterson tweeted that trans actor
Ellen Page she now identifies as a man
named Elliot underwent gender transition
surgery performed by a criminal
physician he wrote remember when Pride
was a sin and Ellen Page just had her
breasts removed by a criminal physician
okay so I was banned because of the
covid thing then I was banned for
literally calling attention to the fact
that Jordan Peters person was banned
because he either misgendered or
whatever you want to call it with Ellen
Elliott page okay so I'm giving you the
personal example of all of these and you
and people
all along for the last couple years when
these when these things would happen uh
you know I'd get an awful lot of support
obviously but then there's another set
of people oh you're paranoid it's a
mistake it's a it's a bug in the system
you know something like that
um and no it actually was all real so
just remember now I'm going to read you
Barry Weiss's thread because Elon Musk
gave her the Twitter files
um just remember that
it all turned out to be true and some of
us did know and we just didn't have all
the pieces in front of us right we were
putting together we were putting
together a puzzle but we didn't know we
didn't have the box to show us what the
puzzle looks like so we're putting
together something that looks like
something but we're going wait a minute
wait a minute the Box doesn't show us
what the final picture is supposed to
look like so battery Weiss you guys know
Barry Weiss formerly of the New York
Times she has been a liberal and a lefty
her entire life I have my political
disagreements and some personal
disagreements with Barry but she left
the New York Times because of how woke
it has become uh so when Elon Musk
decided to release these Twitter files
he went to two people he went to Matt
taibi a lefty also I would say again on
his way to maybe a little more of a
Centrist view as well as Barry Weiss he
went completely around the mainstream
media so this is a long thread but it's
worth hearing all that because this is
this is important stuff and and let me
just say one other thing before we get
to it which is as you guys know if
you're not on Twitter that's great but
you have to know that the way the engine
of the the idea engine of the world
is Twitter and it puts out ideas that
then translate into real world things so
you may not care about Twitter but what
happens on Twitter cares about you okay
here's Barry Weiss's uh tweet thread
which went out at I think around 9pm
last night uh 7 15 p.m last night thread
the Twitter files part two Twitter's
Secret blacklists
a new Twitter files investigation
reveals that teams of Twitter employees
build blacklists prevent disfavored
tweets from trending and actively limit
the visibility of entire accounts or
even trending topics all in secret
without informing users Twitter once had
a mission to give everyone the power to
create and share ideas and information
instantly without barriers along the way
barriers nevertheless were erected take
for example Stanford's Dr J bhattachara
who I've had on the show actually who
argued that covid lockdowns would harm
children Twitter secretly placed him on
a Trends blacklist which prevented his
tweets from trending
or consider the popular right-wing talk
show host Dan bongino who at one point
was slapped with a search Blacklist
Twitter set the account of conservative
activist Charlie Kirk to do not amplify
Twitter denied that it does such things
in 2018 Twitter's Vijaya got a then head
of legal policy and trust and kavan
bakapur head of Prada said we do not
shadow man they added and we certainly
don't Shadow ban based on political
viewpoints or ideology
what many people call Shadow Banning
Twitter Executives and employees called
visibility filtering or VF multiple
high-level sources confirmed its meaning
uh Connor come back to me for a second
so okay so I want to just sit on that
point for just a second when I had
tweeted at Jack years ago
over two years ago do you guys Shadow
ban he said no and as I said to you even
when he responded to me I knew it was a
linguistic trick because there was no
way of pinning him on what does Shadow
Banning mean it was a new phrase that
could mean many different things to many
different people can we go back to seven
again so they decided to call it instead
of Shadow Banning visibility filtering
it's such a perfect
1984-esque orwellian word it's
incredible okay let's go to eight
think about visibility filtering as
being a way for us to suppress what
people see to different levels it's a
very powerful tool one senior Twitter
employee told us visibility filtering
refers to Twitter's control over
visibility it used VF to block searches
of individual users to limit the scope
of a particular tweet's discoverability
and to block select users posts from
ever appearing on the trending page and
from inclusion and hashtag searches all
without users knowledge
we control visibility quite a bit and we
control the amplification of your
content quite a bit and normal people do
not know how much we do one Twitter
engineer told us two additional Twitter
employees confirmed the group that
decided whether to limit the reach of
certain users was the Strategic Response
Team slash Global escalation team or
srt-get it often handled up to 200 cases
a day
but there existed a level Beyond
official ticketing beyond the rank and
file moderators following the company's
policy on paper that is the site
Integrity policy policy escalation
support known as sip PES okay now you
really got to listen to this one guys
this secret group included head of legal
policy and Trust Vijaya got a and Global
head of trust and safety Yol Roth
subsequent CEOs Jack Dorsey and parag
agaral and others here's the key part of
what they did here this is where the
biggest most politically sensitive
decisions got made think High follower
count controversial another Twitter
employee told us for these there would
be no ticket or anything come back to me
for just a sec so you need to understand
there's a difference here so they were
doing things what do I always tell you
guys about big Tech it was never the
things that they were doing that we knew
about that I was worried about it was
all the stuff we didn't know that I was
worried about it now we have something
really big it's not just that average
employees at Twitter could depress
someone's views or hide them from search
or make sure that they didn't Trend then
they had the highest level Executives at
Twitter
Jack and parag and Vijaya these people
where they had in essence what this is
saying is they had a god mode that would
not be ticketed that they were able to
do things that there would be no record
of that's what's going on here so if
they wanted to take out Charlie Kirk Dan
bongino Dave Rubin Jordan Peterson blah
blah blah you they could do it without
there even being a record of what the of
what they were doing now let's continue
this is where the biggest most
politically sensitive decisions got made
think High follower account
controversial another reply told us okay
so I got you so there would be no ticket
or anything okay you got that one one of
the accounts that Rose to this level of
scrutiny was lives of tick tock an
account that was on the trends Blacklist
and was designated do not take action on
user without consulting with SIP PES the
account which Haya raychik began in
November 2020 and now boasts over 1.4
million followers was subjected to six
suspensions in 2022 alone Rachel says
each time raychik was blocked for
posting for as long as a week
Twitter repeatedly informed Rachel that
she had been suspended for violating
Twitter Twitter's policy against hateful
conduct but in an internal sip pest Memo
from October 2022 after her seventh
suspension the committee acknowledged
that LTT Libs of tick tock had not
directly engaged in behavior violative
of the hateful conduct policy see here
the committee Justified her suspensions
internally by claiming her posts
encouraged online harassment of
hospitals and medical providers by
insinuating the gender affirming Health
Care is equivalent to child abuse or
grooming compare this to what happened
when raychik herself was doxed in
November of 2022 a photo of her home
with her address was posted in a tweet
that is garnered more than ten thousand
likes When Rachel told Twitter that her
address had been disseminated she says
that Twitter's support responded with
this message we've reviewed the report
reported content and didn't find it to
be in violation of the Twitter rules no
action has taken the doxing Tweet is
still up
in internal slack messages Twitter
employees spoke of using technicalities
to restrict the visibility of tweets and
subjects here's Joel Roth Twitter's then
Global head of trust and safety in a
direct message to a colleague in early
2021.
six days later in a direct message
within an employee on the health
misinformation privacy and identity
research team Roth requested more
research to support expanding
non-removal policy interventions like
disabling engagements and de-amplifying
visibility and filtering we're almost
there guys Roth wrote the hypothesis
underlying much of what we've been of
what we've implemented is that if
exposure to misinformation directly
causes harm we should use remediations
that reduce exposure and limit the
spread slash virality of content in a
good and limiting the spread virality of
content is a good way to do that he
added we got Jack on board with
implementing this for civic Integrity in
the near term but we're going to need to
make a more robust case to get this into
our repertoire of policy remediations
especially for other policy domains
there's more to come on this story which
was reported by Abigail schreier who's a
friend of mine and I've been on the show
many times Michael schellenberger A
friend of mine who's been on the show
many times Nelly Bowles uh Isaac
grafstein and the team at the Free Press
okay I know that was a lot of reading
and text there uh and I think you guys
got why I felt that I had to read the
whole thing we were going to maybe just
select a couple parts but we now know
for sure Twitter had the tools to shadow
man they had a policy within the company
on how they could do it and how it was
going to be tracked we don't know all of
the people yet we will find out all the
people that were in charge of these
things but we also know that Twitter was
a a wildly woke leftist company right
what did Elon find when he opened up the
closet door and Twitter HQ stay woke
t-shirts right so the employees there
had a political ideology and from what
we can see in the Twitter dump so far
the people that they were going after
whether it's Libs of tick tock or Dan
bongino
or Charlie Kirk these people happen to
be on let's say the right side literally
in figuratively figuratively of politics
right now uh okay so now let's uh let's
go back to the tweet that I sent to uh
Jack back then uh I asked Jack from
Twitter once again I tweeted this last
night I asked Jack from Twitter if they
Shadow banned back in 2020. he hasn't
deleted the tweet yet but he did
unfollow me a few days ago and I tagged
Elon about okay
now here we go have anyone has anyone
been paying attention to any of this
stuff is it possible that there were a
whole bunch of people that were
screaming about this trying to make
sense of this but the whole thing was so
confusing because of all the tricks that
they had that it was very hard to
pinpoint anything and maybe that was by
Design
here is Eric Weinstein back on the Rubin
report in January of 2017 okay this is a
long time ago ladies and gentlemen this
is almost six years ago talking about
the Matrix of information and confusion
that we're in I know enough to say this
is unnatural I don't know enough to say
well the problem is is that Jack had a
meeting at the NSA and they read him the
riot act that's where you get into
territory that I'm just not comfortable
with because I don't know yeah
knowing is kind of important but but a
lot but assume that you can know about
an abstraction but you can't know about
the specific so I think it's really
important that we all get very good at
saying I can tell that this is
artificial and I don't know what caused
it so basically what you're saying is
we're in The Matrix here and a few of us
are kind of starting to see a little bit
of the code shaking out because it's
kind of
it's gotten it's gotten uh it got fat on
itself I guess we were watching a magic
performance that has been performed
every four years
since 1980 at least which is when I sort
of have my first adult memories of of
politics and suddenly somebody threw on
the lights we see trapdoors and we see
wires we see false bottoms of boxes and
everybody's looking at this saying
you're kidding me
okay so that's almost six years ago
he's saying it right there I don't know
if Jack is involved with the NSA and the
intelligence services but I got a hunch
and we better get good at having a hunch
and figuring out what that means you
know how your body sometimes tells you
something when someone's talking to you
and you know that they're lying and you
can't quite place it and your body's
kind of telling you something like wow
you know you kind of just like on alert
a little bit more you just feel
something like that hunch that a whole
bunch of us
uh we're feeling it all turned out to be
true and they kept lying they kept lying
here is Jack Dorsey then Twitter CEO uh
being asked by Sean Hannity in 2018
whether they Shadow been let me ask
about specific questions has Twitter
ever been involved in Shadow Banning we
do not Shadow ban according to political
ideology or Viewpoint or content period
uh no not period yes you do yes you do
and we know it without question he got a
whole bunch of pushback from that
interview because it was so obvious to
so many of us that something was not
right and again I don't want to make
this about the myopic okay it's just
because you're on Twitter all day long
and it's and you're not getting enough
likes or retweets the stuff that happens
on Twitter the battles that happen on
Twitter between politicians and other
politicians OR tech tech magnets and
other people like these are real things
that leak out into the real world so he
got a lot of pushback on that that
interview with Hannity and then he
followed up Jack followed up with this
following up on this without a lot more
in detail with a lot more detail we
don't Shadow ban and we certainly don't
Shadow ban based on political viewpoints
that's a really funny way of saying
something isn't it we don't do the thing
and we especially don't do it the way
you think we do it right that's how much
we don't do the thing that we don't do
we do rank tweets by default to make
Twitter more immediately relevant which
can be flipped off more on ranking
signals now this is where this really
gets good
three days before
I asked Jack whether he Shadow banned
and he said no and this is then two
years after all right because that was
in 2020.
2018 is when Hannity asked him about it
well three days before I asked him about
Shadow Banning Senator Ted Cruz in a
senate hearing about big Tech and
censorship asked him about what Twitter
is doing related to the New York Post
and the hunter Biden laptop and Shadow
Banning and much more ability is you
have the power to force a media out and
let's be clear the New York Post isn't
just some random guy tweeting the New
York Post has the fourth highest
circulation of any newspaper in America
the New York Post is over 200 years old
the New York Post was founded by
Alexander Hamilton and your position is
that that you can sit in Silicon Valley
and demand of the media
that you can tell them what stories they
can publish and you can tell the
American people what reporting they can
hear is that right
no this was this was a you know every
person every account uh every uh
organization that signs up to Twitter
agrees to his terms of service in terms
of service so media Outlets
reflect and obey your dictate if they
wish to be able to communicate with
readers is that right
no not at all we you know we we
recognize an error in this policy and
specifically the enforcement you're
still blocking their photos you're still
blocking their posts right now today
you're blocking their posts we're not
blocking the post anyone can tweet and
the New York Post uh post on there on a
Twitter account if they go into their
account no is your answer to that no
unless they create a reflect and agree
with your dictates anyone can twist them
so the New York Post expense or Politico
presumably you can censor the New York
Times or any other media Outlet Mr
Dorsey who the hell elected you and put
you in charge of what the media are
allowed to report and what the American
people are allowed to hear and why do
you persist in behaving as a democratic
Super PAC
silencing views to the contrary of your
political beliefs
good work there Ted Cruz
I'll get you a beer next time I see you
yeah so that is three days before I then
again asked Jack if they Shadow van he
says no and he the thing is the guy was
obviously lying the entire time Ted Cruz
knew he was lying he said we recognized
an error
he's talking about the hunter Biden
laptop and how they censored the story
that they've recognized an error except
it wasn't an error it was clearly by
Design they had teams of people that it
was their job to do just this to fill
out these tickets make sure certain
things didn't show up in search make
sure things couldn't Trend and that
people couldn't tweet certain things or
DM them
etc etc so he lied I think that that
it's possible that he could be in
trouble because he probably lied under
oath to Ted Cruz whether he lies to me
on Twitter is irrelevant but lying to a
senator under oath about what whether
you Shadow Banner or not and again I
think he'll get a good lawyer and the
good lawyer will just they'll just get
so lost in the word Shadow band sort of
like Bill Clinton uh what's the
definition of is is right
um it depends on the definition of his
that wasn't a good Bill Clinton it
depends on the it depends on the
definition of his how is that but I was
reading it
I used to do a good Bill Clinton wait
I did not have sex with that woman
that's not so great either whatever all
right okay anyway uh anyway last night
all hell is breaking loose on Twitter
people are freaking out and I wanted to
get ahead of one thing because actually
for as bad as the Twitter Shadow Banning
is and whatever else whatever
manipulation they've done there and how
they make things Trend and how they
purposely design trending stories to
make people hate each other and all that
stuff for as bad as all that is I
actually think that YouTube particularly
is manipulating us way more than that
and I think you guys know that uh just
by whatever your viewing habits might be
right there are times you guys tell me
this all the time when I literally
people tell me this when I meet them at
the store or at the airport and then we
get emails about this all the time and I
get it for my own viewing habits there
are times when our videos I'm talking
about Reuben report videos go out to all
sorts of people and we're getting all
sorts of clicks and I look in our
analytics and it's like we're
recommending your videos more and more
people are seeing your videos and people
are interacting with your videos more
and then just out of nowhere
the next day we're not getting
recommended people aren't seeing our
videos I know you subscribe you don't
see it all of these things so I think
YouTube specifically is doing far more
damage so I wanted to throw one tweet
out last night and then something nice
happened here I said let me get ahead of
this one right now I think YouTube and
Google's manipulation for political
purposes is far worse than twitters and
then Elon Musk actually I didn't even
tag him in it but he saw it and uh I
guess it's got him thinking that's the
Curious Emoji isn't there something
going on yeah wouldn't you say anyway
here's the big group here well that's
all that's a huge issue so I don't want
to say here's a bigger issue but a side
issue to all of this is will any of this
information wake up the the certain set
of people who seem impervious to truth
right I keep talking about how we have
to accept that a certain amount of
people are NPCs non-playable characters
that no matter how much you show them
Donald Trump didn't say very fine people
on both sides and Brett Kavanaugh was
not a rapist and all of the stuff right
Jesse smallet hoax and they lied about
that and they lied about the motives for
black lives matter and masks and
everything okay there's a certain amount
of people that are that seem are so
seemingly tied into all of the lies
they're so
um they're so tied into the spirit of
the day or something that they cannot
extricate themselves
from that
so what does the machine do in the face
of this the machine tries to Keep Your
Eye Off the Ball the machine tries to
investigate the people who are actually
exposing the lies and trying to get us a
little closer to something known as
Truth uh here's a headline from
post-millennial about what's going on up
in San Francisco where Twitter
headquarters is San Francisco to
investigate Twitter over HQ providing
beds for employee naps I think we have a
couple beds yeah look at that these are
images of beds Elon Musk since he's been
there because he's working his butt off
he gave himself like a little looks like
a IKEA bed basically and he's put beds
in there so the the city of San
Francisco is now looking into that
because they are not because Twitter's
headquarters are not licensed to be a
place where people can sleep overnight
most of you who have jobs who have had
jobs over the years you sometimes end up
sleeping well sometimes you end up
sleeping at work you know you shouldn't
be and sometimes you know a lawyer
that's working all night might sleep on
a couch something like that but this is
also the the irony of this that San
Francisco is going to spend at one iota
of Manpower or one dollar to look into
Elon Musk and what he's doing at Twitter
relative to the employees and whether
these people are sleeping those cots and
beds look perfectly nice San Francisco
has tens of thousands of people sleeping
on the streets they have crack addicts
and meth addicts everywhere Hunter Biden
could be out there you know what I'm
saying people you know what I'm saying
here's black lesbian sex press secretary
Corrine John Pierre she can't talk about
Twitter in the Biden campaign because
you know it's not like she's a black
lesbian press secretary or anything uh
you've said a few times that you really
can't talk about Communications between
the five campaign and Twitter who is
telling you that that's off limits I
I've already had that conversation with
you with your colleague I believe
yesterday
I've already addressed this multiple
times this week so I don't have anything
more to add again I've I've we've we've
we've litigated this all week don't have
anything to add so I'm going to the back
I'm going to I tweeted this out
yesterday but she is so bad at her job
that she really makes Jen stocky look
like Margaret Thatcher she is so
profoundly terrible she has no answer
for anything her body language the
constant looking down everything about
her reads as inauthentic she's she's
actually I guess you could argue she's
great for the job because she is the
perfect extension of this Administration
which is based in lies and nonsense and
now she has to deal with the soul suck
of waking up every day knowing that all
you are doing is protecting liars and
and bad people but when we let them lie
like this and I and this was Peter
ducey's Point can we find out a little
bit more and she's well we can't talk
about it all he wanted to do was find
out a little bit more like what
coordination has there been between the
administration and Twitter between say
the intelligence Services well we can't
talk about that we talked about that
already really we did did we get a name
did we get an email address can you
point me to a small building somewhere
of course not of course not but what's
this really about in the in a sort of
real politics way right when I always
say it's like okay you may not be on
Twitter but what happens on Twitter
cares about you so how is this stuff
related to what what is going on in the
country right now well when we let them
lie like this it basically creates a
legitimate consequence for all of us
because censorship and the denial of
Truth is a big problem so one thing that
happened yesterday that a lot of people
were happy with and a lot of people were
not so happy with is that uh WNBA player
now the WNBA is the women's basketball
league I don't know why women need a
basketball league because as far as I'm
concerned women are as good as men when
I used to go to the courts as a kid
women were dunking all over everybody
trash talking kicking the [ __ ] out of
you elbows the whole thing
um however for whatever reason women
want their own basketball league I don't
know why if you just made it all based
on skill I'm sure it would probably be I
don't know what do you think 70 women
and 30 percent and in the NBA but
whatever chicks want to play with their
own balls okay fine uh but Brittany
Greiner is a WNBA player she I think she
was the number one pick she's a big star
in the league uh happens to be a lesbian
you know not there's anything wrong with
that uh and happens to be black not that
there's anything wrong with that either
uh and she got arrested and detained in
Russia a while back because she brought
in some weed you can't bring weed into
Russia Russia rules you can't do it uh
anyway we got her back yesterday she had
been wallowing in a gulag I suppose in
Russia we got her back we traded her uh
for a crazy Russian arms dealer who I'm
going to give you more of [ __ ] in just
a second but here is Karin Jean-Pierre
announcing Brittany greiner's release
you'll see how I'm connecting this all
to the Twitter thing
good afternoon everybody
President Biden keeps his promises and
today he fulfilled a deeply important
promise to bring Brittany Greiner home
to a family that loves her a team that
misses her and a country that has
marveled at her strength and courage
okay we got Greiner back now first off
let me just say without without glibness
or sarcasm or anything else I don't want
any American almost regardless of
virtually anything they've done to be
put in a prison in another country and
especially in a case of dislike she
wasn't like massively selling drugs or
anything like that it was her own little
weed stash it's nice to have an American
back
um the problem is that because this
Administration lies about everything
they seem unable to justify why they do
anything because it's all based on
political correctness and wokeness and
everything else we have several other
high-profile prisoners in Russian jails
that it would have made more sense to
swap for than her because we gave up a
guy I'm going to tell you a bit more
about him in just a moment who is a
major major Russian arms dealer so if
you were just if this was a basketball
trade you don't trade you know say this
there's guy is an All-Star you may not
like a Russian arms dealer but he's an
All-Star you don't take a Shaquille
O'Neal in his prime and trade him for
later years
Mugsy Bogues no offense to Mugsy I'm
just doing that based purely on size
right because Mugsy small Shaq big Mugsy
was a great player and for 5-3 I think
or five seven I think it was five seven
to be in the NBA it's incredible sorry
Mugsy Bogues I retract that whole part
of this I think okay anyway uh here is
uh Ducey once again asking Karin jump
here about the logic of this prisoner
swap in this prisoner swap why did
Russia get such a better deal
look you know I've talked about this uh
and I'll say this again
here were our choices our choices was uh
Brittany or no one at all bringing home
one American or no American at all and
that's that National athlete we gave up
a prolific arms dealer who was convicted
of trying to kill Americans who was
called The Merchant of death the
professional athlete is also an American
citizen
so let's not forget that who deserved
and
he's so inept in smug look again as I
said without glibness or sarcasm it's
good to get an American back but you
know if you start making trades that are
completely asymmetrical whether you're a
sports team or a nation trading a
terrorist for dead bodies or an arms
dealer for a wnb player the asymmetry of
that creates a situation where the other
country they go boy look what we can get
back we can get our freaking crazed
Merchant of death arms dealer we can get
him back all we had to do was hijack
this WNBA player that nobody cares about
this is a problem it's just that's just
a problem of international relations so
who is this Merchant of death
arms dealer that we just sent back to
Russia his name is Victor bout I'm going
to show you two videos here uh from 60
minutes in 2011. uh a bit more about
Victor bout and the way I'm linking this
all to the Twitter thing is that when
everything is lies everywhere when
government lies to us and big Tech lies
to us we end up electing the wrong
people incompetency runs rampant because
everyone's just covering for lies
instead of doing good work and doing
what they're supposed to do
so we got Brittany Greiner back and
here's the guy that we gave up for
Brittany Griner
Victor booed uh in in my eyes
um is one of the most dangerous men on
the face of the Earth on the face of the
Earth without a doubt
Mike Braun the former Chief of
operations for the U.S Drug Enforcement
Administration told us boot first
exploded on the scene in war-torn West
Africa in the late 1980s
elevating bloody conflicts from machetes
and single shot rifles to
AK-47s not by the thousands but by the
tens of thousands so he weaponizes Civil
War in Africa he transformed these young
adolescent Warriors into
Insidious mindless maniacally driven
killing machines that operated with
assembly line efficiencies now 43 boot
from the Soviet Republic of Tajikistan
is a mystery man who reportedly served
in the Soviet Air Force and intelligence
service
the U.S has indicted him on four
terror-related charges including
conspiracy to kill Americans okay
um
all right so he sounds like a pretty bad
dude right he you know there were people
killing each other with machetes he gave
them all sorts of weapons murderous
killing machines horrible uh Brittany
Greiner is the only NCAA basketball
player to score both 2000 points and
block 500 shots I don't know that seems
comparable to the mass death and the
murdering and the training and turning
these people into killing machines and
everything else here's a little more on
Victor boot what makes him a threat to
the United States he is a shadow
facilitator he's arming not only
designated terrorist groups Insurgent
groups but he's also arming very
powerful drug trafficking cartels uh
around the globe taking advantage of
Russian military contacts at the highest
levels and the collapse of the Soviet
Union federal prosecutors allege boot
essentially became a One-Stop shop
offering an unlimited supply of
stockpiled Cold War weapons to bad guys
around the world including Charles
Taylor of Liberia who's now on trial for
war crimes according to the U.S
indictment boot had a unique selling
point when it came to weapons
trafficking a fleet of cargo airplanes
capable of transporting weapons and
military equipment anytime anywhere more
than 60 planes in all his own private
Air Force those Russian aircraft were
built like flying dump trucks he could
move this stuff and drop it with
pinpoint accuracy to any Desert to any
jungle to any other remote place in the
world right into the hands of what I
refer to as the Potpourri of global scum
I mean this is like comically insane
this guy had 60 planes that he could
just drop thousands and thousands of
weapons all over the place keep arm
conflicts going Godly knows what money
laundering and what else was going on
there the amount of people that were
killed at his hands
and uh you know we got back Brittany
Greiner two thousand I don't want to
diminish 2 000 points 500 blocks those
are not easy numbers to accumulate over
a career but I don't think the girl had
60 planes filled with basketballs
dropping them off all over Africa to
help the young kids out there uh if you
want to get a sense of how silly this
whole story is we also have well it's I
guess it's silly it's depressing it's
just it it's so perfect for the
administration right uh Russia has other
Americans in detention right now one of
them is a marine by the name of Paul
Whelan uh Benny Johnson you guys know
Benny Johnson I've had him on the show a
couple times he had a great tweet so of
course what you're seeing down there on
the left is Brittany Greiner uh on the
right is Paul Whelan he wrote meet
Brittany Greiner and Marine Paul Whelan
both Americans both were convicted in
Russian courts on dubious charges both
serving multi-year sentences in Russia
prison Brittany hates America Paul
served America guess which one Biden
traded for a traded a terrorist to free
Semper Fi Paul so Paul welan it's a
little murky some of the details of why
he was uh detained perhaps has something
to do with spying I'm not even saying
this is a complete Apples to Apples
comparison but I think it's fairly
obvious to anyone
that we got the short end of the stick
here but why would we get the short end
of the stick and now this will also
connect back to everything in woke world
that we're talking about lately well why
why was it so important to get her back
well she was sort of an apex predator of
the oppression Olympics uh pyramid right
I mean she's a black lesbian this is
primo stuffed people Paul wheelan's a
white dude I think straight what do we
need him for
Don lemon's very excited because this is
good for the gays I think I would be
remiss if we did not mention also the
importance this plays for the lgbtq
community as we've been talking about
black women this is big so this is for
the lgbtq community glad releasing a
statement obviously just I'm summarizing
here that they're happy and it shows the
the struggles and the danger that
members of the LGBT community face
around the world what the high hell are
you talking about lemon she's what she
wasn't arrested for being a lesbo she
was arrested for
spit take uh she wasn't arrested for
being a lesbian she was arrested for
smuggling drugs into the company into
the country this has nothing to do
with LGBT anything there's no such thing
as the LGBT community if there is I
don't want anything to do with it these
people are just all completely
ridiculous but that is the most
important thing you think Don lemon's
going to do a segment on Paul Whelan I
don't think so I don't think so anyway
one more clip from the Corrine
Jean-Pierre press conference yesterday
because she was just getting hit left
and right and she's terrible absolutely
terrible at her job and she's dismissive
and smug and condescending and all of
those things and finally she just
couldn't take it anymore she left
can you take a question
why is it so hard to take a question on
the U.S Africa Summit when the president
is in 50 African leaders the biggest
garden of leaders of his administration
where is it hard for you to give me a
question it is not hard I've answered
would you let me answer the question or
are you okay
okay trying to answer your question go
ahead sir go ahead I just tried you
wouldn't let me go ahead I just tried
and you would not let me sir so your
colleague is going to ask a question go
ahead no I just I literally just tried
to answer your question you shut me down
so now your colleague is gonna
be okay I'll see you tomorrow yeah
question out of respect for America
a good not a good day at the office for
Corinne Jean-Pierre but it's good to see
that there is some pushback and and the
point of all of this is not only because
when we let lies spread either knowingly
or unknowingly and that's what the
connection is between the first half of
the show today that lies were spreading
because we were depressing truth we end
up electing incompetent people are we we
have an Administration in front of us
that lies about everything we have a
president with who obviously has
dementia we have all of these problems
that we know did not have to be problems
that actually weren't problems just a
couple years ago but then when you think
how how did they do all the stuff how
did they do it well they had their their
fingers on the levers or the swipers of
who could see what and when they could
see it so then you end up voting in the
wrong people you end up not
understanding basic Notions of what
democracy is or why you should care
about any of this stuff or anything else
so let's go a little bit further about
how these people lie because their lies
now we know have been fueled without
question because it's not just that they
could suppress some people they could
inflate some people and who got inflated
and fellated more than anyone over the
last couple years well certainly it was
mad scientist I am the science Dr
Anthony fauci who of course is stepping
aside but this was just a good one
talking to the Washington Post that he
would never do anything over he did it
all right people this guy's just perfect
first I want to ask you
is there a moment of your career that
you wish you could do over
you know
um
Yasmin no and I know they're gonna
people are going to respond to that
um who say well what does he think he's
perfect absolutely I'm the first to
admit I'm far from perfect but when you
say do over
you know I really can't see something
that I would do completely over
yeah remember remember the quote at the
beginning of the show Alexander
Solutions yeah they know we know we know
they know they know we know and they
continue to do it that's the definition
of what he is because he knows he's been
exposed at every level he knows his
emails about not masking and then
masking he knows the videos where he
said don't uh where he said lock schools
down and then he does other other videos
saying I never said he knows it's all
out there but it just doesn't matter
right and they're making fun of you at
the exact same time so not only is fauci
getting out of the way which is great
but Trevor Noah who was was because he's
stepping down now or he's being kicked
out and he should have been kicked out
years ago because he took the Daily Show
over from Jon Stewart The Daily Show was
whether you agreed with Jon Stewart or
not and he's certainly gone off the woke
deep end Jon Stewart subsequently from
The Daily Show but tons of people did
watch The Daily Show when Jon Stewart
had it Trevor Noah took over nobody
watched you never saw a viral Eclipse it
never became relevant in any real way
again so they finally got rid of him and
they obviously would have gotten rid of
him earlier had he been white but he got
his privilege points and that's okay
that's fine that's how these
corporations work I just wanted to throw
back to this moment because this this
sort of encapsulates what he was this
moment mocking Americans who were
complaining about lockdowns and you know
after hearing the story I would love to
see an American citizen and a Chinese
citizen sit down to talk about covid
because you always hear Americans
talking about how they feel as though
they were oppressed by the covert
restrictions here yeah the Chinese
person would be like it was brutal I was
literally bottled up in my home beaten
up by the police and sent to a
quarantined Camp be like I feel you
brother this one summer I got asked to
leave an Applebee's we are not different
at all my friend we both suffer
smug to come you know it's it's so
interesting when you see first
generation immigrants that come to this
country to be so hateful of this country
this is sort of the ilhan Omar syndrome
right like she came here he came here
you end up becoming millionaires or
congress people you're you're so close
to like the seat of power and you come
here to make fun of people because they
wanted to live freely sorry uh sorry
Trevor Noah that we were not quite as
bad as uh China but you know what it was
far worse than being kicked out of an
Applebee's but it continues with these
people who seemingly get everything
wrong one of them and this one is a
massive disappointment this one is just
a massive disappointment if you would
have asked me like four years ago what
show I wanted to do more than any other
show it was Howard Stern's show I grew
up on Howard Stern grew up in New York
City I was listening to Howard Stern
when he was on terrestrial radio before
he got onto satellite radio and when
every day he was fighting the executives
and fighting for free speech and all of
that stuff well covert broke him Trump
broke him he's just become absolutely
crazy this is from uh from outkick
Howard Stern thinks Kirsty Ally's
opposition to vaccine mandates against
covid-19 caused her colon cancer death
she was anti-mandate maybe she didn't go
to the doctor soon enough when she
wasn't feeling well Howard said it's
just so vile it's so vile by the way if
you didn't hear Kirsty alley who was a
wonderful actress she was on Cheers and
she was saying look who's talking and a
whole bunch of other stuff she passed
away of colon cancer a couple days ago
she was a conservative she was outspoken
politically
um I don't think I said this publicly
but over the last year we had sort of
become friendly we were actually
beginning to work on a sitcom for her
with a couple other people we had a
really great concept for a sitcom that
she was super excited about this I
apparently kicked in out of nowhere
anyway Stern has no idea
what what led to her uh what led to her
death I mean we know it was colon cancer
but he has no idea what her personal
medical decisions were and being against
a mandate has nothing to with nothing to
do with how people take care of their
internal personal medical practices
right so let's get this thing full
circle why stopping them when they lie
matters because they'll keep coming
they'll keep sending out more fauces
they'll keep sending out you know who
will lie and and Institute policies that
will affect your life then they will
keep sending out more Corinne
jean-pierre's to lie about the lies
right they will keep hiring ridiculous
bureaucrats like any of the people who
just did this trade for Brittany Greiner
for The Merchant of death they will keep
doing all of these things and they will
do it as we expose the lies in real time
so the opportunity here guys is there is
a moment there is a little bit of a
moment right now where if you can reach
out to your friends who have been
brainwashed by all of the stuff and say
to them hey you know here's this here's
this uh this Twitter thread by Barry
Weiss who was a New York Times
journalist who was a lefty her whole
life who now is exposing some of the
censorship of Twitter do you think that
that is legit you think that that is
good do you think silencing people is
good enough you may you may not be able
to have that conversation because I know
it's it's awfully hard to do
it is awfully hard to do but we have a
little bit of a moment to get a little
Mojo that that's actually what I felt
like this morning I woke up this morning
after all the craziness of Twitter last
night I kind of felt I feel I wake up
with purpose and a sense of what I'm
doing every day and everything else
um but I felt a little extra Mojo this
morning like yeah I was kind of right
about a lot of things I don't think it's
because I'm Clairvoyant or because I'm
so brilliant or anything like that I
actually think it's just because I had
my hand to the ground and some level of
sanity and I did not go crazy because of
all of these things and then when you
when you don't do that
the truth will set you free and I think
that's the path that a lot of us are on
right now and that's a good path because
you know what happens if we don't stay
on that path of knowing what our rights
are knowing what we believe and why we
believe it they will keep a coming they
will keep a coming with Allah as they
will keep a coming with the lockdowns
and they will keep coming with with far
worse things uh Jordan Peterson actually
talked about some of those far worse
things with Rita panahi on Sky News
Australia do you think what we did
during covert could usher in our version
of a social credit system oh yes
definitely yeah yeah and that is highly
probable and that it will be accepted by
many people because again
they won't notice even yeah you can't
believe how much people don't know these
things when I went to the UK I talked to
some people from the House of Lords this
is within the last six months the most
astute of the people sitting in the
House of Lords had only become aware of
the woke movement in the last 18 months
oh yes you just can't believe how much
this is not on people's radar not
someone like you can't believe that at
all because it's on your radar all the
time that's not you live in a world
that's on The Cutting Edge of this sort
of thing it's like people have no idea
it's like well why not have a digital
passport
I mean you know how convenient like fair
enough and you can understand that
wouldn't it be nice if we could pay for
everything with our phones it's like
wouldn't it be nice if the central
government who's woke oriented and makes
carbon dioxide remediation the priority
knows exactly what you spend on
everything so they can Target you tax
wise with Precision it's like oh didn't
think about that it's like yeah
yeah you sure didn't and oh yes it's
highly probable it'll be in a miracle if
we
if we escape from that you can see these
signs of this everywhere you know when
you go through airports now there's a
lot of automated barriers you show your
passports like
well these are automated barriers what
if you can't go through them
well that's the situation for many
people in China it's like what are you
going to do you're going to argue with
the machine like you just cannot imagine
how screwed you are there isn't it's way
worse than anything Kafka ever imagined
because at least with Kafka there was
bureaucrats
faceless though they may have been they
were at least Still Human once the
machines can lock you out
you are in such trouble and we're
speeding towards that with uh
with an immense lack of
of care you see why it's important to be
awake I would say if you watch this show
you're probably
an edge case on the front end of this as
he described to Rita meaning that you
you are aware of some of this stuff you
probably didn't lose your mind over the
couple years even though we were all
given these horrific choices to make
about going to work or being vaccinated
or all these things but we saw some of
the stuff we were willing to question
some of the things all of those things
and a certain amount of people aren't
and then a certain amount of people as
Jordan's laying out will one day after
the digital passports are in and all of
the stuff they'll get to the airport
they'll scan their thing and the Machine
will tell them no you can't get on that
plane
you liked this video or you did this or
that or were freeze in your bank account
so all of these tests have been running
throughout the West it just is guys but
now Elon is exposing it and that should
give you some serious freaking oomph
behind your desire to keep going all of
our desire to keep going because the
world's richest man is putting his butt
on the line to expose some of this stuff
and wake up more people and we just need
more people to wake up and by the way
Jordan's example of showing up to the
airport and then not being able to get
past the machine that's not that crazy
right first off it's happening in China
right now but just think about your how
we relate to the machines in our
day-to-day life now most of you watching
this probably have Gmail accounts if you
had a problem with your Gmail account
what do you do
can you speak to a human as he said at
least in a kafka-esque novel uh there be
a faceless bureaucrat you can't get
anyone on the phone at Google there's no
such thing the machines have already
taken over to a degree so
wake up fight push
be competent oh good segue Ron DeSantis
some people say hey these local
governments wanted to lock down
businesses they wanted to force mandates
they wanted to keep the kids locked out
of school yeah you're damn right I
overruled them on that because
and the fact of the matter is the fact
of the matter is you you don't have
rights that you don't have the right to
do wrong and if I had not stepped in
last year and made sure that these local
governments couldn't lock you down
couldn't mandate we get we wouldn't let
them find we had kids in school last
year because of me not because
yeah that's all I have to say to that
yeah that's what you need people you
need a little bit of that spirit and
then what happens a whole bunch of
people that don't even know you start
cheering for you because you did the
right thing
guys stick around for a cold close in
just a moment I think we're about to
enter along the show every territory
right now we're there we're going to be
there in about two minutes comments from
the locals Community Margot says work on
that accent Dave you're in the South now
all right I want to do that I used to do
a pretty good build
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman
Hillary that was that that was pretty
good I did not have sick it depends on
your definition of these eels okay not
great roses says I think they really
believe they know best they are just so
smart hell they got trophies and ribbons
for just showing up to soccer when they
were five you know that's funny I
remember I kid you not you guys probably
had this all the time but I remember I'm
46 years old I remember being in fifth
grade so what year I'm in fifth grade
that's got to be around 85 about nine
years old something like that I remember
we were doing a field day and I wasn't a
good athlete really until probably late
Junior High into high school that's when
I really started getting good at stuff
so and we were we had like a field day
out there you know you do all different
things your egg carry and the bike that
you got to go slow and all that stuff
and I didn't place in anything and I
remember getting it was a yellow piece
of paper about this half the size of a
regular thing and it was I don't
remember if it said participation trophy
or something but you know you we're out
there today and you didn't you didn't
kill yourself and I remember thinking
this is messed up nobody should get this
piece of paper what am I going to do
with this piece of paper I'm going to
put it on the Gaylord focker Hall of
Fame thing
Peter that's a good reference if anyone
got that you got that yeah uh Peter says
uh it's the gas lighting I hate the most
we all knew what was going on yeah
we have been gaslit guys the the media
corporations big Tech they have lied to
us about all these things but that's the
chance that's the chance right because
now it's being exposed so again it's
it's what you do with it within your
life now knowing something a little bit
more approximate to the truth and then
how do you export some of that stuff
because really the issue is so Elon can
can drop all these uh truth bombs right
he can he can say boy we did all that
they did all this stuff related to the
to the hunter Biden laptop and maybe
some other stuff election related and I
think we're obviously going to get way
more covid related right in the barriers
thread there there was the one thing uh
covid related but we're gonna get way
more information about what they did
related to covid
um
but the point is that we're going to
find out all of this stuff but a certain
set of people will not pay attention no
matter what and as that goes on as as we
as the years go by with that right and a
certain set of people let's just say and
I know it's easy for us let's just say
we're a little closer to truth than the
other half right
so we're going down that path and we're
going to make some mistakes we're gonna
we're gonna screw up some things uh
we're not going to get our predictions
right like I I got a lot of the the Red
Wave predictions wrong although now I
don't know if you heard but this morning
Chris did you hear this Christian Cinema
we didn't even talk about it this
morning Kirsten Cinema Democrat from
Arizona senator she just left the
Democratic party so we're back in a tie
she's an independent now she'll probably
caucus with the Democrats but this is
this is a great moment anyway you're
going to get some predictions along a
law of wrong along the way but let's
just say we keep going down our path we
whatever that means people in red States
people who are somewhat red pilled
people who are functional and have jobs
and believe in family and all that stuff
so we're going to keep going down that
path and then there's this other set of
people who always believe in the thing
the thing of the day the outrage of the
day that's partly why they have to keep
them outraged outrage Burns hot but it
burns pretty quick so you gotta you can
get everybody to put the Ukraine flag on
and I'm for chopping kids genitals off
and black lives matter and all these
things but you got to keep them going
through all that nonsense we gotta do
the best we can to deprogram some of
those people but they're gonna just keep
going that way one of the things I've
been thinking about lately is I think
we're going to end up I think we're sort
of there already we're in two different
ideological worlds sort of mentally but
I think we'll continue to go that way
physically in terms of red and blue
States and then I think another version
of this will be that I think it's very
possible
we're going to end up in two completely
different internets I really do think
that there's going to be something like
that I have to flesh out the thought a
little bit more but that basically there
will be sort of an a Twitter sort of
Elon Musk basic respect for truth and
free speech and and American principles
internet and then there'll just be this
very hyper-controlled
um NPC internet where there won't be a
lot of discussion but you will get
authoritative information and if you
question it we're going to kick you out
and then you'll end up with the freaks
on the other side it's going to be
something like that I gotta I gotta work
that one through a little bit more
anyway longest show we've ever done
people despite the fact I didn't
complain I've got the coven still my
line I took the test again yesterday and
again I'm only testing because I got the
kids here they're doing just fine but my
line was a little thinner yesterday I
think by the end of today I'll be all
right and everything will be fine for
the weekend oh I'm very excited you guys
know what I'm doing tomorrow night
I'm going to see Frankie Valli Frankie
Valli 84 years young he's still doing it
people I'm going to see Frankie Valli
tomorrow night can't wait have a great
weekend everybody the truth will set you
free and we leave you with because we
didn't give you enough of them here's a
little more Jordan Peterson you do not
have the power to twist or distort
reality without it snapping back at you
in ways that you can hardly possibly
imagine you think that lying protects
you that's wrong and you think well how
could it possibly protect you what
you're trying to do is to adapt to the
world and if you lie so that you're no
longer adapted to the world then you're
gonna run into sharp objects and and
fall into holes Non-Stop and the Blinder
you are the sharper the objects and the
deeper the holes and when you really
understand that like once I understood
socialit's connection between lying and
the totalitarian state well there's no
way I'm going to say things that are
false because that's clearly that's the
road to hell not metaphysically not
philosophically actually really for sure
this will happen and as a clinician this
is is one of the things that also
terrified me I never saw anyone ever get
away with anything
the chickens always came home to roost
people paid for every sin
sometimes it took them years to draw the
causal connections